si un seigneur de la nuit s'accouple
avec une femme non vampire elle mettra
au monde un
empire les
Balcans
[Musique]
1992 je sais pas qui ou quoi est
derrière tout ça le diable en personne
vousez appeler
leampire
j'ai toujours eu des cauchemars mais ils
sont plus présents et
réels des souvenirs quiont surf c'est
très
déroutant les seigneurs de la nuit tu ce
que ton espèce à la naissance vous êtes
trop
dangereux et maintenant Gor que tu
existes son but sera de t'exterminer tu
peux m'amener à lui amène-le jusqu'à ma
salle de
torture alors tu es qui au
[Musique]
juste que peuton bien ressentir quand on
réalise que la fin est proche s'il te
plat
laisse-toi guider par ta voix
[Musique]
intérieur la guerre va être longue dans
ce
cas bienvenue dans un monde de cauchemar
[Musique]
commandant